I at work and I'm at unit 48 in the
Vulcan I've looked at the Vulcan for
about seven months and become spinning
for about two years a little bit more
this is a beginning to intermediate
tutorial designed to bring people from
beginning pub spinning to intermediate
close to first is grips this is called a
ring grip the club is between my thumb
and the index finger kind of the wedding
it's good for circles down and in front
pumping him back to the side in the
front and the back on both sides this is
clogged green I can swing the club in a
circle holding the club like a claw it's
really good for up and in front down on
him back to the side and front and
decide in the back if those two grips
you can do a lot of coin oceans one of
the first things you wanna learn is to
eat i'm doing a circle and regrip and a
circling habra the club is doing
combining these two drips I can move
through point motions around my auntie I
can move under my arm over my arm behind
my back to the other side of my back
behind my head around my head and
between my legs
there's also pointer which can use for
point moves but I recommend just
learning to manipulate the club with
your hands I use a laser pointer grip to
teach anti spins and Hagrid's in general
it seems to be the most useful grip calm
for these motions it's like if the club
had a laser and we're shooting on the
wall I'm gonna write my name and what
this does is it gives a lot of leverage
we find leverage between the index
finger and the thumb I can do that
little rubber banding trick from high
school grade school that teaches me
leverage in clubs fitting we often use
the reference points them down left and
right up right up left down you can do
it to eat to the different reference
points of your bottle
you can do spin flowers switching ribs
and miss me or NT sniff flowers and what
you want to know the group is dynamic is
changing all the time so as you learn to
manipulate the clothes more fluidly the
whole appearance becomes more smooth you
can watch toast at videos or boy videos
and get a lot of ideas let's talk about
timing and direction there are two
timings and two directions for two
points rotating around the circle let's
just do this with our arms first we're
going to move in split saying which
means that the hands are split they hit
the bottom of the top on split beats and
they're moving the same direction the
other same where the hands are moving
together observer looking to hit the top
in the bottom at the same time and
they're moving in the same direction
it's together opposite for the hands are
hitting the bottom and top of the circle
together with their moving in opposite
directions there's also split opposite
for the hands are split and talk about
but moving in an opposite direction you
can do all this timing in directions
with your clothes as well here's what it
looks like split sing together same
together opposite
and slows
a minim will be pattern is a one-to-one
ratio that means that for every civility
artist there's another circle of the
club's purpose circle of my arm there's
a circle of the club similarly in
isolation for every circle of my arm
there's one sir for the club even an
anti spin the club is one full circle
for a repetition of my off the grid we
use for minimum beat club patterns it's
like a circle with a plus sign inside
the plus sign is a vertical axis up and
down and a horizontal axis left and
right we got the reference points of
left and right up and down and we can
move through the reference points in all
sorts of ways the property indication
away from your body or toward your body
on the horizontal axis or the vertical
axis when you have two phones you can be
pointing in both for your body build
away from your body for one toward your
body and one away from your body each of
these reference points also your hands
can be split blinking both toward both
away or one chord one away that's called
propagating let's learn the four basic
shapes if it will be club patterns they
are isolation extension vertical
enticement
and he spit these can be done in all
four times and directions extension is
when the club is pointing away from your
bottom and your arm is moving in a
circle in the same direction as the club
isolation is when your club is pointing
toward your body in a hand is moving in
a circle in the same direction as your
club and it's been changes for going
away from your body to toward your body
away from your body and then towards
your body again as the club moves in the
opposite direction around the circle as
the arm this is a vertical intestine and
this is a horizontal and vertical
anti-spin will point away at the bottom
and the top and will point in at the
side and the other side horizontally its
pinnacle point away at the side and the
other side but point in at the bottom
and the top laser pointer what I do is I
hold the leverage of the club between my
thumb and my middle and index fingers
also sort of near the webbing of my hand
it's very easy to switch from rain grip
into this laser pointer grip which helps
with anti-spin isolation and extension
you can switch very easily between a
laser pointer grip and an extension by
popping the club back on your arm and
anti-skid the club up drop into that
leverage and
now this position over here the laser
pointers really nice this club is
resting on arm and at any point from
these four I can shoot out to an enemy's
bit while your office here it's very
easy to go into isolation your arms
supporting the club I grab the leverage
to move the club you can see these more
fundamental shapes in all four times and
directions in my video 16 Club patties
if you combine these shapes together you
get with all the hybrid the two clubs
are doing two different types of motion
at the same time ultimately it can mean
that the clothes and the hands are in
different timings and directions for an
example of an extension for google
anti-spin i'll begin with blue clubs
pointing out at the bottom I focus a
little bit more on my auntie spin
because it's more difficult than the
extension the hands of you notice aren't
together saying that the clubs are
moving like a butterfly through together
opposite you'll notice they point to
each side at the sides both down at the
bottom each side of the sides and both
up at the top which is the exact same
reference points be used for together
opposite let's do it again hands are
moving around the circle together
together saying well the club we're
moving in together opposite i'm using
vertical and you spit with my right hand
and extension with my life so this one's
going to do an isolation well this one
does
it looks something like this you can
also choose to anti spin the other way
or to complete that pattern you can
watch my video 24 club hybrids for more
ideas for hybrids one thing to remember
is that there is no strict way to do
clothes fit in it's a static problem
which means you can move it however you
want for a while it may seem like
unturned butter but if you keep churning
the butter I promise to get students